last week a team from the White House
went to Singapore to meet with the North
Koreans to set up the whole summit that
team sat on the ground for three days
the North Koreans never showed there was
word that they were going to go back
again tonight that was off than it was
back on now there was talk swirling here
around the White House that in fact that
team may be headed back to Singapore to
meet with the North Koreans and get this
summit back on track sometime this
weekend what a difference a day makes 24
hours after he sent a letter to Kim
jong-un canceling their summit President
Trump today said it might be back on see
what happens we're talking to them now
we're talking to them now they very much
want to do it we're gonna see what
happens
the turnaround happened after an
uncharacteristically diplomatic response
from North Korea to the letter North
Korea saying it is still willing to meet
the u.s. at any time in any format
adding we remain unchanged in our
willingness to do everything we can for
the peace and stability of the Korean
Peninsula we are willing to give the
United States time and opportunity
president Trump responding in kind on
Twitter quote very good news to receive
the warm and productive statement from
North Korea we will soon see where it
will lead hopefully to long and enduring
prosperity in peace only time and talent
will tell at the White House aides
rushed to contact their counterparts in
North Korea to try to put things back
together for June 12th with the caveat
that North Korea needs to be serious
about coming to the table as the
president said this morning certainly
we'd like to have a meeting but the
president's not just looking to have a
meeting he's not looking for just a
cheap political stunt he wants to get
something that's a long lasting and
actual real solutions as the White House
prepared to send back to Singapore an
advanced team the North Koreans stood up
last weekend Democrats said the
president should have used that as the
reason for postponing the summit rather
than the White House has stated
rationale for canceling it that there
should be no meeting if North Korean
officials are going to threaten nuclear
confrontation what we should have done
is simply announced the
we were delaying the summit to a date
not designated and say the reason for it
was that they didn't show up to the
planning meeting if they don't show up
to the planning meeting it's hard to
plan and get things done by June 12th
but by canceling it it makes them look
like they're more interested in peace
than we are that's a mistake and
president Trump tells Fox News he has
reached a deal with Xi Jinping to save
Chinese telecom giant ZTE after the US
Commerce Department effectively
shuttered ZTE for sanctions violations
in North Korea and Iran
she called president Trump to appeal the
loss of Chinese jobs she initially
offered a fine of 500 million dollars
they had to change out the management at
board of ZTE president Trump insisted to
find be higher 1.5 billion in addition
to management and board changes
president Trump also wanted security
guarantees and a promise that ZTE will
buy most of its components from US
companies she countered with a billion
dollar fine president Trump told Fox
News they eventually settled on 1.3
billion the announcement of a deal drew
fire from the president's own party
Senator Marco Rubio tweeting yes they
have a deal in mind it's a great deal
for ZTE in China China crushes US
companies with no mercy and they use
these telecom companies to spy and steal
from us many hope this time would be
different now Congress will need to act
not surprisingly Democrats were critical
of the deal as well the House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi calling it quote a
staggering betrayal of the American
people President Trump insisted to Fox
News that he has been far tougher on ZTE
than the Obama administration ever was
the Obama administration recently
considered sanctions against ZTE and
then backed off President Trump telling
me yesterday I shut down ZTE